now moving on I've crunched the numbers
I can reveal it is time for our next
guest here's Eddie word
I love mathematics magician Eddie Wu has
been uploading lessons on his very own
rutube channel for years cocking up more
than 20 million views many people think
of mathematics as dollar formulas in a
textbook and it could not be further
from the truth the head maths teacher
from cherrybrook technology High School
in Sydney uploads his actual classes
school bell and order does anyone have
anywhere to run to you at lunchtime with
a knack for making mats fun Eddy has
been listed as one of the world's top 10
teachers on your mark get set go
move and start flipping back home he's
been named one of this year's Australian
local heroes and it's easy to see why
Australia's local hero for 2018 is Eddy
wound
Freddie I want to know can your love of
maths be done in a quantifiable
measurement oh wow they say it's pretty
tough to measure the infinite but things
you just gotta tell me thank you I'm not
gonna understand anymore you can
understand some things I don't think you
need to be quantified to know how big
they are like for example how much it
must have burned when Sarah compared
yourself ease to childbirth there's a
lot of funny cat videos on YouTube
they're fabulous but how do you get kids
to tune into maths videos when your
would show PageRank which I love yes you
know what Sarah I've often wondered that
myself because you know people are doing
this freely in their own time and for me
I think it's maybe that personal
connection maybe most people haven't
experienced mathematics is something to
do with people and with stories and with
surprise and curiosity but to be able to
convey that to my students and for that
to some of that to make its way through
the lens I think that's what people are
tapping into and it's what's happening
in lots of classrooms around the country
but I've gotten to open a window into
that into my god just so adorable
incredible how much teenagers love you
my niece and nephew refused to watch
anything I do but they've been texting
me asking me because specifically what
time maybe blue so your new book was
wonderful world of maths is about to be
released you're tackling big questions
including wire left-handers why aren't
they extinct I didn't know we were under
threat I'm also unclear as to why that's
a mathematical question well a lot of
things I have come to be surprised by
how much is mathematics deeply woven
into them but you wouldn't first think
up so my brother my dad both left-handed
and I kind of got very much impressed
there I mean they're amazing right there
must have meant to be more intelligent
than the rest of us but the left-handers
sort of have a hard life around the
world you know throughout history people
have disliked
left-handers so you know evolution
should have said you know survival of
the fittest why are they still stuck
around and in fact there's this
mathematical equilibrium but actually
left-handers by being a little more rare
than everyone else actually get a bit of
a competitive advantage your rare but
dislike all you the Kim Kardashian of
maths I'm assuming that's cuz you can
bounce a champagne glass oh I didn't
think my feet who sort of goes in that
direction but for me if people being
positive and celebrating a subject which
often hasn't been enjoyed by people
around the world yeah if that's a new
kind of stage they're going to then I
guess a comparison of Kim K I can run
with you getting recognized in the
streets oh look I will say I have a
fairly common face
that really gives me where is my voice
actually because kids are watching me on
their phone on this tiny little square
but they can hear me from a mile away so
if I talk to my kids they're like I knew
that voice I can't believe that when you
first started out you didn't love maths
all that much I failed math in the beer
garden at school people have a math
spray or not and can you learn it if you
pick up I think it's a very common
misconception that there's a max brain
or an English brain and for me I think
it's a bit like saying or some people
hands people and other people feet
people I mean some people can do
something amazing with a musical
instrument or what Serena can do with
her tennis racquet and that's obviously
a gift but it's also been honed with
time and practice and you know I quite
enjoy good sport I reckon if I gave it a
go someone likes she could train me I
could improve in that way and that's
certainly been my mathematical journey
it wasn't something that came naturally
may have no affinity for it but we time
and patience and some great guidance
that's what's helped me growing it I
thought you mean if you're into hands or
feet which has got a foot
what's 2742 time 68 ah I really have no
idea I'd call it around did you say 2000
[Applause]